[Music]
>> Hi.
I'm Ashley Feniello.
I'm an engineer in the Research
and AI Group.
We're working on a platform
that's for doing systems like
this.
This is one of the applications.
It's a mobile directions robot.
We have it in Building 99
normally with a building map
there, and you can ask it to
take you to conference rooms, to
people's offices.
It can give people a tour.
It's built using this platform
called the Platform for Situated
Intelligence.
And lots of componentry that's
in place already for some of the
best human perception components
and there's a bridge to ROS for
using some of the low level
control components there.
The research interest is
essentially in adding more
social awareness to systems like
this.
So things like understanding
multi-party engagement.
So, for example, our group of
people walks up to the robot, he
needs to understand whether the
people are talking to each other
or talking to the robot, when is
a good time to interrupt, things
like that.
Also classifying human
activities.
So it can make decisions based
on that.
And some more socially
appropriate navigation, like
staying to the right in
hallways, boarding elevators
properly, not cutting between
people if they're talking and
things like that.
That's the basic idea.
It's a platform for us to
further social robotics
research.
Thanks.